[Evans] The answer is the cost per bit for a hard drive
is approximately 0.01 nanodollars per bit.
Remember a nanodollar is a billionth of a dollar,
so this is a cent of a billionth of a dollar per bit.
The latency distance, though, is quite high.
It's 2098 kilometers.
So that means accessing data from the hard drive
is like traveling between Munich and Moscow.
This is a pretty big difference between accessing data from the DRAM memory,
which is only about 3 meters away, about what you can reach with your arms,
which is again very different from accessing data from the CPU,
which is the distance between your thumb and your finger.
So when people write programs and they care about performance,
you really have to think about memory quite a bit.
You have to make sure that the data that you access frequently
is stored in these close, fast-to-reach places,
not in the hard drive, which is like traveling between Munich and Moscow
to get to your data.
And no one is storing data in light bulbs.